six one seven eight three zero 4750 is
the number let's try because this could
be a pseudo local call could be someone
even that knows Pat let's go to the 508
area kono let's go to 508 who's this hi
Alex
I want to give a theory that I think I
called in I give it you an invoice Bell
but basically this is if Trump is still
in office by June of this year yeah
doing the investigation hasn't taken him
out yet I see this scenario coming to be
so right before you give us the full
thing Alex before you give us the full
thing this is the key question are we on
speakerphone right now please take us
off speakerphone and we'll be glad to
listen al you're not ears it's bad okay
good yep please all right
sorry about that so basically 2018 World
Cup is coming up it's in Russia Putin
has used these big national you know he
did it with Sochi to just to drum up
support for his invasion of Ukraine okay
yeah right now he's got a hundred
thousand troops in Belarus basically can
control the country if he wants to okay
sometime after the World Cup say he
takes control of this country Trump now
has a choice publicly because if there
is some sort of dirt where he's not
allowed to criticize Putin publicly
because he's never done it he has to
either respond whether it's
diplomatically or militarily to Russian
aggression or he has to do nothing but
then everybody knows that he's a Russian
mole so if Putin does something
aggressive then in my opinion Trump is
forced to publicly reveal you know his
hand that's just my take what do you do
for a living Alex you still with us Alex
you could be hung up it's intrapersonal
weird I was interesting um okay well
listen if Trump is still president in
June then we'll evaluate Alex's
hypothesis have any feedback on that I
don't have any feedback and you look
like you also don't know okay that does
it for calls for this week we will talk
to you next week thanks to everybody who
called in